my back is gonna be way out okay
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
ready
okay
our gear weighs nearly 75 pounds and is
too heavy to carry up this ladder so
we're gonna catch it on the sea floor
like Navy SEALs do when they hide their
gear until it can be retrieved to later
the danger is when we're resurfacing
you've got to make sure you continually
breathe out if we hold our breath as we
ascend the change in pressure is going
to expand the air inside your lungs and
can cause them to rupture
goodra you can decline
well okay so that's where the other
groups who are going to get three all
right we went in the water drip down we
swam for a bit and they've got pitch
black
this might not look right Chrissy I mean
like scary dark the next thing you know
we're in a cave but now we're about to
crawl through what looks to be a birth
canal
okay we're good
oh really
can to Sardinia for their comfort oh
okay good
oh that's how they access this clip
I've got our clothes and our boots and
backpacks and stuff let's get geared up
we do a lot of things on these journeys
and that was definitely though for me
was on the edge and is committing just
because one thing goes wrong in a cave
like that in the dark you can I mean you
can feel in here this swell you know it
goes wrong very fast I may just have a
look down there's like a cauldron but
we're now into this journey we're
committed and the only way from here is
up
[Music]